so we have two rooms that we use we have
a mix of scenery a lot of its being used
at the moment but then Northampton
wargamers meet in the upstairs of a gig
venue on Tuesday night it's just enough
to play games a small community with one
rule you don't talk about politics it
gets a bit heated at times people people
come here to play games we will come
here to get away from you know there
monday to friday nine till five they
want to turn up they want to roll some
dice and just talk crap with their
friends thankfully tonight the ceasefire
is being voluntarily violated strikers
most of the club's members are male and
in their 20s just the sort of people
referendum campaigners want to reach out
to they turned on each other now space
screens about space moons brother on
brother and it as a guy acted civil war
effectively EU referendum is that talked
about quite lavoie again would you like
to be able to avoid me when you watch
the news you would sometimes you what I
want to avoid the news because both
sides are so negative and so so biting
so Ted school probably just bolster this
these girls with the hobby like this
these young men know all about
battlefield strategy what's their view
of the referendum campaigns so far
I think both sides are going about it
the wrong way in what way their fear
mongering I think the best solution
would be education please people at the
EU does nobody's ever talked to us as
like a community of young people I'm not
seeing anyone even i'm currently at
college normally at college is currently
talking about nobody's educating us as
to whether or not to stay or not you
guys one in the other room the flick of
a card can destroy entire armies and
civilizations but it's quiet and calm
very too long that is until I bring up
the referendum and disturb the peace
what what are you telling me is going to
be better what what is there going to be
eating I don't get I don't understand is
how situation so all of a sudden we're
going to make more houses no no no we'll
have more so immigration will drop
obviously because we're at the you we're
going to lose a little bit but don't
worry because we're not part of Europe
and what does that mean well I mean it's
a leap of faith so it seems the members
here were willing enough to break their
number-one rule the quick straw poll are
done here tonight suggests to me that
here at least the young people are
mainly voting along the lines of the
polls and choosing remains but there are
still quite a few undecided
with just days left then the pressures
on for campaigners to target communities
of young people like this there are
clearly still votes to the one in all
corners of the country Joe tidy Sky News
in Northampton